في غضون ذلك اكدت وزاره الدفاع في
بيلاروسيا ناموس قوه مس كثافه تدريبات
العسكريه المشتركه بناءا على ما اكتسبت
روسيا من خبره في القتال في اوكرانيا مع
التركيز على ما وصفوه بحرب المدن هذا
وقالت وزاره الدفاع انها عزز التعاونها مع
نظيرتها الروسيه حيث تخططان لاجراء
تدريبات جويه مشتركه واشارت الى ان
التدريبات على حرب المدن تحضى باهتمام خاص
في هذه المناورات وياتي تعاون العسكري
المكثف بين البلدين الحليفيين وسطك هناك
في اوكرانيا والغرب بان موسكو قد تستغل
منصه الانطلاقه والانطلاق وشنه هجوم جديد
على اوكرانيا من جهه الشمال
هذا وافاد تقرير بريطاني بان القوات
الروسيه تعزز دفاعاتها في منطقتي زبرجيا
ولوجاز باوكرانيا تحسبا طبعا لهجوم كبيره
للقوات الاوكرانيه التقرير رجح ان يشكل
تحقيق القوات الاوكرانيه لتقدم كبير في
سابولجيا تحديا للجسر البريه روسي الذي
يربط منطقه رستوف الروسيه مع شبه جزيره
القرم اما في مدينه باخمود فلا تزال
المعارك تحت دم فيما تدور معارك داريه
وسطى سوليدار بمقاطعه دنيا اسعد حيث
يتواصل القصف المتبادل لدفع الجيش
الاوكرانيه على الانسحاب قبل ذلك وقبل ذلك
ايضا استئنا فتى القوه الروسيه قصف مناطق
بالشرق اوكرانيا عقب انتهاء الهده التي
اعلنها الجيش والرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
وصدقارير عن تعبئه روسيه جديده لاستقدام
500,000 جندي للقتال في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
في هذه الاسماء ينضم الينا من دنياك مراسل
العربيه رائد الاغبر رائد كيف هي الصوره
من هناك بعد هذه العمليه الروسيه التي
تعتبر يعني الاضخم والاكبر منذ بدايه هذه
الحرب
ليال مساء الخير بالفعل يعني هدنا انتهت
وبدات بعدها استئناف القصف المتبادل من
الطرفين هناك ثلاث نقاط هامه الاولى هي
قصف القوات الاوكرانيه لمحطتين لانتاج
الكهرباء في مقاطعه بانيت يعني عبر صواريخ
استراتيجيه صواريخ
وصواريخ توشكاو الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه
اسقطت صاروخ
نحو احدى المحطات
يعني لم ااه يعني فشلت هذه العمليه بينما
العمليه الثانيه لن تستطيع الدفاعات
الجويه اصابه صواريخ
قصفت
المحطه لكنها لم تصب باضرار كبيره قتلت
امراتين وهناك منهم ما زالوا تحت الانقاذ
حتى الان هذه هي النقطه الاولى والنقطه
التاليه هي ما اسلفت عنه عن وضع
متواسينيبار في شمال مقاطعه دانيت القوات
الروسيه والقوات الخاصه
المجموعات الخاصه الغير مرتبطه بالجيش
الروسي ما زالت تطوق مدينه باتنه من شتى
النواحي من الناحيه الجنوبيه والناحيه
الشرقيه
وبالامس استطاعت ان تطوقها من الناحيه
الشماليه بعد ان طوقت مع مدينه باطما بلده
سليدار استطاعت ان تسيطر على بلده صغيره
عن احباط روسي لهجوم اوكرانيا بمحو
اردونيس تحديدا هل لديك اي معطيات او
معلومات حول هذه العمليه
الجيش الروسي او الدفاع الروسيه بشكل يومي
تحبط عمليات كبيره لتقدم القوات
الاوكرانيه خاصه في محور دانيت المرتبط مع
خاركب ولوجان
هي التي تحدث عنها الجيش الروسي او الدفاع
الروسيه حيث ان القوات الروسيه والدفاع
الروسيه تشير الى انها سيطرت على الطريقه
السريع في منطقه سباته على اطراف
وانها قامت قوسين او ادنى من الوصول الى
مكان تمركز القوات الروسيه التي انسحبت من
مدينتي الايمان وكبيانس لكن الدفاع
الروسيه وبشكل الرسميه تقول بانها تقصف كل
القوه الاوكرانيه التي تتقدم في هذا
المحور وتحيد مئات الجنود لم يسيطر حتى
الان حسب الدفاع الروسيه وحسبه السلطات
العسكريه المحليه اذا سمح لنا همم هناك
محور هام جدا وهو القصب الروسي الانتقام
بعمليه الثا
ر التي ذهب اطراء هذا القصف الاوكراني
اكثر من 70 او 80 ضحيه روسيه قالت الدفاع
الروسيه بانها قصفت موقعين مختلفين بسلاح
الجو المقاتله الروسيه قصفت بصواريخ
استراتيجيه موقعين فيهما تجمعين للقوات
الاوكرانيه احدهما كان يشمل 700 مقاتل
وثاني كان فيه 600 مقاتل اوكراني ذهب ضحيه
هذا القصر من الجيش الاوكراني حسب
التصريحات الروسيه اكثر من فئه 600
والباقي ما زالوا تحت الانقاذ بين ربما
يكون قديم شكرا لك مراسل العربيه رائد
الاخبار على هذه المعطيات طبعا سنكون معكم
مجددا في حال ورود اي جديد من هناك